and I guess in people's careers you know
actress the audition for things that's
one thing but then you have to do that
terrible waiting to hear if you get the
part and Harry didn't you everything
with you auditioned for a Sandra Bullock
that's right it was a movie called hope
floats uh and and it was one of the
first movies I did this was I don't know
I was maybe in my late 20s I guess and I
really wanted to do this part and it was
between me and some other guy in the
part that I was playing was a guy from
Texas he was like a real cowboy and they
may not seem like a lot of distinction
to y'all between Texas and Louisiana but
where I'm from there's a big difference
I mean you think of Cowboys you know
don't really think of the state that I'm
from even though it's right next door to
Texas well Sandra told me the guy that
I'm really thinking about is this cowboy
from Texas and the part was a cowboy
from Texas I said there's no way I'm
gonna get it so it was time to fly back
from Texas to Los Angeles Sandra was
being flown back on the on a private
plane that the movie studio was paying
for I was just taking a commercial
flight so she said if you want to ride
back with me come on and ride back with
me so we get on the plane and I was
trying to be coy and not let her know
what I was thinking but I really wanted
to know who this other guy was so I was
sitting on the plane with my back to the
pilot and she was sitting right across
from me like you are and I'm like so how
did that other guy do he's pretty good
huh yeah he was really good he's from
Texas he's exactly what we're looking
for I'm like wow so you know he's
probably like got a lot of good luck
going on and he's famous and she starts
to untuck her shirt and I'm thinking
okay it's not particularly warm in here
but she wants to so she starts
unbuttoning her shirt and what was
really weird was that her father was
actually on the flight too and I'm like
you know you're I mean this is as freaky
as it gets I mean your dad is right
there you taking your clothes off in
front of me on a private plane like
maybe I don't want to work with you
after all
his thoughts on button in her shirt and
she worked such raising her shirt up
this is Sandra Bullock and on her
stomach was written you got the
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]